[Music]
foreign
[Music]
director of product management from
Google cloud and I'm joined by my
colleague Jerome Sims I am r
and we're both excited to share with you
some new products and capabilities we're
introducing at next this year as Amar
said I'm Jerome Sims director of product
management at Google and I'm focused on
Google's devops portfolio it's great to
be here with Amar to share these
exciting updates with our devops
assistant men and operator friends now
Amar will kick off the session
thank you Jerome at Google Cloud our
mission is to accelerate every
organization's journey to digitally
transform the business and when it comes
to devops we serve customers of all
sizes and types today and our goal is to
make devops on Google Cloud easy for
your organization as well and to fulfill
this Mission we focus on four key areas
which address the key challenges we hear
from these customers every day
first is security
in devops has become increasingly
critical and we are seeing more and more
hackers preying on the security
vulnerabilities of your software supply
chain today number two multi-cloud
more and more organizations are adopting
multi-cloud today and your devops teams
are being asked to support such
multi-cloud deployments
however this is not easy
how do we ensure efficiency security and
consistency as we develop deliver and
deploy across multiple clouds this
becomes a critical challenge
number three sustainability
given the global climate change
all organizations are rising to the
challenge now Google has long been a
Pioneer in achieving sustainability in
our internal operations and now we want
to provide tools to support sustainable
development and operations for all
organizations
and finally
integrating and scaling your devops tool
chain
this is still a challenge for many
organizations
and to fulfill this Mission we focus on
four key areas which address the key
challenges we hear from these customers
every day this year we are launching
many new products and capabilities
across all of these four areas and now
I'm going to hand over to my colleague
Jerome to tell you more thanks Samar
let's dive into some details of our
announcements today to help you better
protect your software Supply chains
we're very excited to bring you software
delivery Shield
software delivery Shield is a
comprehensive yet modular set of
capabilities that spans a set of Google
Cloud products delivering a fully
managed end-to-end solution to help
protect your software supply chain to
help you better secure your applications
during development we are launching
Cloud workstations
a new service which provides a fully
managed local development environment on
Google cloud with built-in security
measures more than that we are also
giving your developers tools to help
them code faster with greater security
with Cloud code Source protect
developers will get real-time security
feedback as they work in their IDE when
your developers are coding in Cloud
workstations artifact registry and
container analysis can give them a
secure space to store and manage their
container images and language packages
and also scan them for vulnerabilities
you can now do unpush scanning for Maven
and go packages in containers and for
non-containerized Maven packages as well
to help you improve the security of your
open source dependencies are a short
open source software service provides
over 250 packages across
Java and python it also includes
verifiable salsa build provenance in
continuing to help secure your pipelines
I'm really excited to announce Cloud
build our fully managed continuous
integration platform now supports salsa
level 3 bills
finally
to help secure the runtime environment
we're introducing a new set of security
features in gke gke can now help assess
your container security posture and give
you active security guidance it also
includes many out of the box security
capabilities for customers on cloud run
our serverless platform we're
introducing new enhancements to Cloud
runs security panel it now displays
software supply chain security insights
such as the salsa build level compliance
information build Providence and
vulnerabilities found in running
services
when your developers are building
application oftentimes they will need
databases I'm happy to introduce Cloud
SQL security recommender with security
recommender it can now automatically
monitor the security posture of your
databases alert you on potential
security vulnerabilities and also
provide guidance to help mitigate the
risks to make multi-clown easier for you
we're introducing a set of new features
to our anthos platform anthos customers
can now enjoy a unified management
experience everywhere from a single
Google Cloud console and to drive
consistent security governance and
observability across a fleet of clusters
spanning all environments in addition
ansos now supports VM deployments for
your Edge environments sustainability
has been a core value of Google from the
very beginning and to help our customers
develop and operate more sustainably I
am pleased to announce that carbon
footprint is now generally available
carbon footprint introduces a new level
of transparency to support you in
meeting your climate goals integrating
and scaling your devops tool chain is a
challenge for many devops teams and for
that I'm happy to announce our managed
service for Prometheus is now GA with
this service there is no longer a need
to Federate ad resources manually or
devote time to maintaining your
monitoring infrastructure you can focus
on scaling your business and not
Prometheus
in addition to make continuous
deployment easier for you we added
integration between Cloud deploy our
fully managed continuous deployment
service and Cloud run our leading
serverless runtime environment
log information is very useful for our
devops teams and to make the use of logs
easier on Google Cloud I'm excited to
announce log analytics a new feature of
cloud logging through an Innovative
partnership with bigquery Cloud logging
now allows your devops teams to get more
value out of the logs through the power
of SQL queries well everyone that's
everything I have today our teams work
super hard to bring you all these new
products and capabilities and I hope
you're as excited about them as I am now
let me pass it back to Omar
thanks Jerome for sharing those exciting
announcements with us
with these capabilities your
organization can adopt a more secure
intelligent and sustainable devops
practice on behalf of Jerome and I we
hope you have a great next 2022.
[Music]